Prof: I said at the
start of the last lecture that
after the episodes that I will
be discussing then,
the cave of Montesinos and
Master Peter's puppet show,
three significant new
developments take place in
the Quixote;
I want to go over them again.
The first is that Don Quixote
will sometimes not be the center
of the action,
which will focus instead on
Sancho.
The second is that both
protagonists become objects of
amusement for aristocratic
frivolous characters that have
read Part I and want them to
behave according to it.
The third is that Don Quixote
and Sancho will be surrounded by
many more characters than
before.
The overarching theme of the
novel continues to be
desengaño and most
of the episodes are staged by
authors within the fiction,
which is highly theatrical,
and the backstage of the
pranks,
the stage machinery as it were,
is revealed to the reader,
either during their performance
or right after.
The episode of the enchanted
boat,
of which I gave you an
illustration of which appears in
the handout that I gave you,
was needed to get our
protagonists across the Ebro
river;
and we're going to show a map
of Spain, although we have
already shown you a map about
where this appears.
We have to get them across Ebro
river--I forgot my pointer
today--but you can see the Ebro
right there.
In Part I, the territory that
Don Quixote and Sancho covered
was not very specific in
geographic terms.
Seville is mentioned as the
destination of the prostitutes
at the first inn,
and also it is mentioned as the
destination of Andrés,
when he reappears.
The Sierra Morena is the
setting for Don Quixote's
penance, and the place where
Cardenio is hiding in shame and
in madness.
This relative vagueness is
consistent with the narrator's
refusal to mention the village
where Alonso Quijano lives,
and to which Don Quixote
returns.
Now, however,
in Part II, geography becomes
much more precise,
starting with El Toboso,
our protagonist's first stop,
which is a real village in
Castile,
and continuing with their
original destination,
Saragossa, where Don Quixote
wants to participate in jousts
celebrated on St.
George's Day--April
twenty-third,
and we talked about that in one
of my earlier classes.
A stream figures in the episode
of the fulling hammers,
but now Don Quixote and Sancho
on their way to Saragossa have
to get across the Ebro,
one of the major rivers of
Spain.
We can see another image
of--there you are--of the Ebro.
I highlight this because,
of course,
Castile is not only landlocked,
but there is very little water
in Castile,
and this is reflected in the
novel where it only rains once
in Part I,
there is that stream where the
fulling hammers appear,
but on the whole there is very
little water.
I'm going to turn the lights
back on.
So the second part adds
geographic concreteness to its
realistic portrayal of Spanish
life.
This is not new with Cervantes.
This he derives from the
picaresque.
In Lazarillo de Tormes,
Tormes is a river;
it's the river that goes
through Salamanca,
as a matter of fact.
And in the Guzmán de
Alfarache,
the geography is quite precise,
both in Spain and in Italy,
where Guzmán travels
also through Italy.
So Cervantes has derived this
concreteness from the
picaresque,
but the episode of the
enchanted boat also serves to
highlight--
comically, of course--the
difference between Don Quixote's
obsolete Ptolemaic notions of
geography and the new Copernican
conception of the universe,
which is being expanded both as
knowledge and as a field of
knowledge as Cervantes writes.
What I mean by that is the
Copernican universe is infinite,
the Ptolemaic universe is
limited.
Now, this--Galileo was making
important discoveries in favor
of Copernicanism in the early
decades of the seventeenth
century--
he was in Spain for a
while--and developing
instruments of observation,
like the telescope.
But Don Quixote still adheres
to Ptolemaic ideas and
calculations,
as he demonstrates in his
hilarious exchange with Sancho,
when he asks his squire to
check if he has any lice on his
body,
because it was common lore that
upon crossing the equator all
such vermin would perish,
as if by magic.
Sancho discovers that his flees
or lice are still very much
alive, and he underscores the
plural when saying that he has a
few.
Like chivalry,
Ptolemaic geography is a
medieval retention struggling to
survive in a world in which
after the discovery and
settlement of the New World it
was wholly untenable,
except to the likes of Don
Quixote or to Sancho,
who doesn't care either way.
It doesn't make any difference
to Sancho, of course.
The crossing of the river is
significant also because our
characters are moving beyond
landlocked Castile,
toward coastal regions of Spain
that are in touch with other
cultures and languages,
and in this second part we will
reach such areas Barcelona where
Catalan is spoke.
The episode is a rewriting,
since we're talking always
about these episodes of Part II
being rewritings of episodes of
Part I,
this episode to me is a
rewriting of the windmills
episode in Part I,
because of the wheels in the
river,
with similar results,
except that Don Quixote and
Sancho have,
again, to make restitutions for
damages,
and as all crossings,
this crossings also a
transition.
Now, I have given you a handout
with the scene of Don Quixote's
exchange with Sancho on the
issue of the distance they have
traveled in--
and as this exchange appears in
various English translations,
so that we can be amused by the
efforts that the translators
make to render it into English
the puns that are involved,
which are a little bit obscene
in the Spanish,
if you have your handout,
if not, I have copies.
Does anybody need one?
After Sancho wonders how much
they have traveled,
he said:
"'Mucho,' replicó
Don Quijote,
'porque de trescientos sesenta
grados que contiene el globo del
agua y de la tierra según
el cómputo de Ptolomeo,
que fue el mayor
cosmógrafo que se sabe,
la mitad habremos caminado
llegando a la línea que
he dicho.'
'Por Dios' dijo Sancho,
'que vuesa merced me trae por
testigo de lo que dice a una
gentil persona,
puto y gafo,
con la añadidura de
meón,
o meo, o no sé
cómo.'"
I think I explained in the last
class the ugly word in Spanish
to say to urinate is
"mear,"
equivalent in English of
"to piss,"
and,
of course, in the word,
in Ptolemy,
in Spanish,
"Ptolomeo,"
there seems to be included the
first person singular of the
indicative of the word
"mear,"
"yo meo,"
this is what Sancho hears in
Ptolomeo's name;
And "c&oacut
e;mputo,"
computation,
of course, to him what he hears
is "puto,"
which is the masculine of
"puta,"
which is whore and it means
homosexual.
So what Don Quixote has told
him lacks all authority;
is what he's saying when his
authorities have to do with a
person who is a homosexual and
someone how pisses a lot,
and this is what Sancho hears.
The efforts by our translator,
by Jarvis,
is not very good:
"'By the lord,' quoth
Sancho,
'your worship has brought a
very pretty fellow,
that same Tolmy [how d'you call
him?]
with his amputation to vouch
the truth of what you
say.'"
He's trying to get
"computation"
and "amputation"
to try to get the pun;
it's not very funny.
It's not very good.
Smollett, in the same
eighteenth century tries to get:
"'For God!' cried Sancho,
your worship has brought a set
of rare witnesses to prove the
truth of what you say.
Copulation and Kiss-me-Gaffer,
with the addition of
Tool-i'-me, or some such
name.'"
This is actually better,
because it catches the spirit
of the obscenity of what Sancho
is saying.
Our own Rutherford,
from Oxford University:
"'Good God,' said Sancho,
'that's a fine character you've
dredged up as a witness,
with his sexy butts and his
tomfoolery,
and what's more a great
pornographer,
or whatever it was you
said.'"
These are all efforts.
The point is that,
of course, Cervantes is making
fun of the whole Ptolemaic
system,
which by this time is obsolete,
but Don Quixote,
of course, is invoking it,
as his authority to tell where
it is that they're going as they
ride on the boat.
You can amuse yourselves in
trying your hand at translating
that pun, if you want.
Now, when Don Quixote and
Sancho arrive at the house of
the duke and duchess they enter
a realm of games and frivolity
that they have not known before.
These are irresponsible
aristocrats that belong to the
leisure class;
in fact, the house in which the
action takes place is not even
their regular house,
it is a summer home for
recreation.
Don Quixote first meets the
Duchess, who his out falcon
hunting, all decked out for the
occasion and surrounded by an
entourage.
This business of hunting with
falcons was very ceremonial,
people just went out with
servants,
and so forth,
and the falcons,
the hawks,
were trained to catch the prey,
and so forth.
There wasn't much real exercise
involved, I think,
as the hawks did all of the
work, but this is part of the
recreation of these aristocrats.
The duke and duchess are
devoted to pleasure,
one of which is obviously
reading, for they know Part I of
the Quixote quite well.
They are idle readers,
like the one Cervantes
addressed at the beginning of
Part I,
and I underline
"idle"
in this description.
Don Quixote and Sancho are like
toys to the duke and duchess,
or better, they are like
literary characters,
which, in fact,
that's exactly what they are.
Everything in their home--I
mean, Don Quixote and Sancho
have sort of fallen on the
hands,
of these people who are great
readers of Part I,
and, wow!, here we have the
"real"
quote/unquote,
Don Quixote and Sancho at our
own home,
and so they try to make the
best of it.
Everything in the duke and
duchess's home is like fiction,
except that fiction can be
harsh and cruel.
What their fiction proves,
the truth of their fiction is
that reality,
too, is like fiction,
and that both reality and
fiction can hurt.
Actually, what appears here is
that reality is always reality
plus the props to create the
fiction;
it's not reality by itself,
but reality improved by or
changed by the props.
This is the harshness of
desengaño.
Not only that being deluded can
be hurtful, and to be un-deluded
also can be hurtful,
but that the physical process
may indeed involve injury.
Peter E. Russell,
a distinguished British
hispanist says,
quote: "The duke and
duchess are remarkably unfeeling
aristocratic pranksters.
Some of their jokes involve
causing physical harm to their
two guests."
You will see that Don Quixote
is scratched by cats,
that the fall from
Clavileño,
the horse, is very dangerous,
and so forth.
He adds, Russell:
"Social satire directed at
various levels of society is
more prominent in these chapters
than anywhere else in the
book."
Now, this is true:
social satire is very,
very important in these
chapters of the book.
In addition,
and this is a detail that I
hope you pick up when you get to
this part,
if you haven't gotten there
yet, the duke and duchess's
expensive pleasures are
underwritten by the peasant
whose son does not want to marry
Dueña Rodriguez's
daughter,
which is the reason why no
pressure is put on him by his
master.
Remember, there is this
conflict, another one of these
conflicts on young people,
this young man has promised to
marry Dueña Rodriguez's
daughter,
because he has impregnated her,
and so forth,
and she complains that no
pressure is brought upon this
young man because his father,
who is a poor peasant within
the realm controlled by the duke
and duchess,
lends them money,
lends them money at very
opportune moments;
that is, when the duke and
duchess are in dire economic
straits.
This is a very significant
detail.
These are not only idle upper
classes, but upper classes in
hock, that finance their high
living with loans.
Since you are readers of
Elliott's Imperial Spain,
you will no doubt see that it
is easy to draw an analogy
between the behavior of these
aristocrats and the policies of
the Spanish crown,
which lives off the shipments
of precious metals from the New
World and loans from the
Fugger's,
the German bankers who finance
the expensive pleasures of the
Hapsburgs at their court:
the building of the palace,
or the Retiro that you may
still see in Madrid.
Velázquez paints these
Hapsburgs hunting and engaging
in these kinds of pleasures,
too.
All of that,
or most of that,
was underwritten by loans from
German bankers,
so this is all part of the
political site of the 1615
Quixote,
which I mentioned before,
is the first political novel,
it's a social satire which may
involve a political dimension.
In this context,
Sancho's social aspirations do
not appear that outlandish,
in the sense that Cervantes is
showing that the social order
and its hierarchies is crumbling
when the upper classes are so
corrupt,
and as is evident in that a
peasant,
a mere peasant is supporting
these aristocrats in their
activities.
So this is kind of a
topsy-turvy world,
the social world which bespeaks
of erosion and of crumbling of
this social order,
and what Cervantes is
dramatizing here is that a new
order is in the making,
in which class mobility may
very well be possible,
class mobility up or down.
We see characters,
like the steward,
in this household of the duke
and duchess,
who has enormous power over his
masters,
and we see Sancho,
of course, elevated,
even if it is fictional,
to governor of this island,
finally.
So the second part of the
Quixote reveals,
as I say, a social order that
is not as stable as it used to
be,
that is sort of shaking,
and he is giving us very
precise--
Cervantes is giving us--very
precise financial details about
this,
through this satire.
The kind of financial detail
that you expect to find only in
nineteenth century novels,
such as Balzac's novel,
in which, of course,
the financial dealings of the
characters play a very important
role.
But here, already,
in Cervantes,
we have these details such as
the fact that the duke gets
loans from this peasant.
Fiction, as performed at the
duke's house,
is mirthful and playful,
but also cruel and uncaring,
as I said.
Fiction is also ephemeral and
substantial, like the props that
hold it up.
With the duke and duchess,
Don Quixote and Sancho
temporarily realize their
dreams: Don Quixote is treated
like a great knight,
and Sancho is finally made
governor of an island,
when Don Quixote enters into
the duke's palatial summer home
they have prompted already their
help so that they treat Don
Quixote as a great personage and
have all kinds of things ready
for his comfort.
But these fabrications quickly
disappear.
It is, again,
desengaño:
the truth of fiction is that it
illuminates the fictional
quality of real life,
or the ephemeral quality of
real life if you want.
An American hispanist,
Ruth El-Saffar--let me put her
name.
It's part of the name,
she was married to someone of
Arabic origin.
She died very young, tragically;
she was a Cervantes scholar.
She writes, quote:
"All of Part II is based
on the mistaken assumption on
the part of the would-be
all-controlling character
authors that they can deal with
a fictional character and
maintain,
at the same time,
a distance, which allows them
never to slip into that
fictional world with which they
plan to entertain themselves.
Like Sansón [continues
El Safar], they are trapped from
two directions,
they are controlled.
to some extent,
from within their play by the
very characters whom they intend
to manipulate,
and from without by an author
of whom they are unaware,
by whose will and whose hand
all they do is contrived."
Unquote.
As we have seen already in the
case of Sansón Carrasco,
this controlling author,
that he falls into his own
trap.
He loses to Don Quixote in this
encounter that they have,
and we will see,
once and again,
that the steward,
who is a very clever fellow and
creates all of these elaborate
pranks does not succeed with
him, okay?
Eventually they come tumbling
down.
So Sansón Carrasco is
the principle internal author,
as I said, and as we've seen
from the very beginning,
bent on recreating the fiction
of Part I,
but now the duke's house,
the duke's steward,
will compete with Sansón
quite favorably.
He is the creator of elaborate
pranks,
like the island where Sancho
will be governor,
like the pageant in the forest,
about which I will speak very
soon,
none of which turn out quite as
he planned them,
and within which he gets caught.
This steward,
by the way, if you think about
the pageant in the forest,
was not only a clever in
creating these pranks,
but he was also a poet,
he must have written the lines
that Merlin delivers in this
pageant.
The significance of all of
this, apart from its baroque
character,
is that Cervantes is
speculating, as usual,
about his own position
vis-à-vis his own
fiction,
this fiction that seems to be
always getting away from him,
and this is what the presence
of these internal authors,
who are beset by these problems
of distance and control,
reveals, which is the same kind
of situation in which Master
Peter finds himself with his
puppet theater with catastrophic
results.
So, then, one of the early
events that occur at the duke
and duchess's house is,
I'm sure you noticed,
is the debate Don Quixote has
with the ecclesiastic.
This is a criticism of the
church, not of religion,
and may also be a commentary on
Spanish politics and the role
that the clergy is allowed to
play in them.
So we have, again,
another instance here of this
social and political criticism
that appears in the novel.
Don Quixote intimates that the
ecclesiastic is a leech living
at the expense of the duke and
duchess,
who in turn live off of the
rich peasant who gives them
loans.
Don Quixote also tells him that
he speaks without authority
because he lacks experience,
and accuses him of acting
aggressively because he is
protected by his investiture,
meaning that Don Quixote cannot
challenge him to a fight because
he is an ecclesiastic,
and therefore he takes
advantage of that protection to
be able to act with this
haughtiness.
But notice that there is some
truth to what the ecclesiastic
says to the duke and duchess
about how they're dealing with
Don Quixote,
encouraging him to go on with
his insanity about being a
knight-errant.
There are no uniformly negative
characters in Cervantes,
even this very unpleasant
priest is right in some of the
things that he says.
He ruins the whole dinner,
he's very unpleasant but he
has--some of the things he
says--are quite true.
Perspectivism,
as we have been seeing
throughout the semester,
means that no one is in
possession of the entire truth,
that is, the truth made up of
the various points of view of
the characters,
and that they truth may be
spoken by the most unlikely
people,
even people who are not very
pleasant.
This is a constant in Cervantes.
Notice that the debate with the
ecclesiastic is,
in this case,
we could call it a pre-prandial
speech;
it's a speech before dinner,
which is ruined,
anyway, by this.
And that it is,
again, another rewriting of the
arms and letters speech,
because Don Quixote always
seems to be able to get to that
topic,
as he did at the house of Diego
de Miranda when he debated about
the virtues of poetry and of the
military.
Now, we move on now to episodes
that are quite independent,
and that seem to build not on
Part I but on previous episodes
of Part II.
It's this fiction issuing from
fiction,
it's like a telescope that
you're pulling out from within
itself what is happening in
these episodes that follow now.
Think of it as that,
a telescope,
and as you pull it out you are
pulling things from within it,
and that is the way that these
episodes that I'm going to
discuss now appear in Part II.
These are very important
episodes, not quite on the level
of the cave of Montesinos,
but very important and very
memorable episodes,
and that sort of make a
coherent unit,
although there will be a return
to the duke and duchess's house
when Don Quixote is on his way
back home.
So we begin by the episode of
the hunt, and we have here,
again, this effect of the
receding sequences.
The episode of the hunt and the
elaborate pageant in the forest
are games within games,
plays within plays.
What is the hunt?
The hunt is a mock war.
Aristocrats no longer
participate in wars,
as we have been seeing all
along, so they now engage in
mock wars, specifically in
hunting.
We saw that both Don Quixote
and Don Diego de Miranda are
hunters.
The hunting of the boar
involves strategies that are
akin to those of a battle,
demanding horsemanship as well
as a playing of drums and
various horns and trumpets;
much of the ceremonial aspects
of war are reproduced in
hunting.
War has become a sport,
and sports, modern sports,
too, are mock wars.
Think for a moment of American
football,
which is--the metaphor of war,
is very crass in American
football: I invade your
territory whereas the other team
defends his territory,
and so there is a dividing
line, which is like the frontier
between these two countries at
war,
and all of the terminology is
derived from the military.
All of this what I call back
and forth sports,
hockey, soccer,
football, lacrosse,
are back and forth,
because you stand there and
they go back and forth,
back and forth,
are a crass metaphor for war.
If a Martian got off his
spaceship and you took him to a
football game,
the Martian would be able to
understand very soon what is
going on,
not so with baseball,
by the way, but in baseball the
war metaphor is very elaborate:
you run around the bases in a
circle to come back home,
like Ulysses, and all of that.
Yes, yes, this is not just a
defense of baseball,
because as you know I've
written quite a bit on baseball
and played the game a lot,
but it is simply the truth.
These other sports that I've
mentioned and hunting,
of course, are crass metaphors
for war.
In baseball,
the metaphor is more--it's
baroque, actually,
it's that convoluted and
distant.
But the outcome,
of course, of sports contests
are like wars,
I think it's tomorrow,
the New York Yankees,
who have just won the World
Series,
last night, are going to be
paraded down the streets of New
York,
with ticker tapes,
as if they had been returning
heroes like those in Rome who
came back and built arches and
so forth.
So much for sports,
but I want to underline the
fact that hunting has become a
sport, and this is what these
aristocrats are engaged in.
Sancho, of course,
runs up the tree scared by this
boar which--these are dangerous
animals with the long tusks like
this, and all of that.
Now, as in Camacho's wedding,
notice the transition,
the episode of the whole
pageant in the forest,
begins with a killed animal,
as if a scapegoat were needed
to start the action,
and also a scapegoat were
needed for the feast.
Feast ceremonies and parties
seem to demand a scapegoat of
some sort.
It doesn't have to be a goat,
of course,
it can be a turkey,
at Thanksgiving,
and so forth,
or it could be a pig in many
celebrations,
but it seems to be an atavistic
need of the human race to have
these scapegoats.
There have been recent
instances in Spain,
I have seen it discussed in the
newspapers,
where new traditions of this
kind have emerged,
and the towns have the practice
that when they have their big
feast they take a goat up on the
church steeple and throw him off
and kill him that way.
Gross.
But what I'm underlining is at
the beginning,
the killing of this boar here
has sort of an atavistic
ritualistic air to it.
Now, this pageant in the forest
is one of the most baroque
episodes in the whole of the
Quixote.
The episode gathers elements of
the cave of Montesinos and the
wagon of the parliament of
death;
it is a kind of synthesis of
both.
This is what I meant by
episodes that are derived from
episodes like a telescope that
you open like that,
but it also a version,
or more accurately,
a perversion of a certain
moment in Dante's
Purgatorio,
and I gave you a handout in the
previous class with a fragment
of Purgatorio XXIX,
because these episodes here,
as I will describe in some
detail,
are a take of,
a parody, of these episodes in
the Divine Comedy,
no less.
I told you that,
now, Cervantes' sources are not
just the romances of chivalry
but Ovid, Virgil,
Homer and Dante.
Now, in Dante's Commedia
this is a moment of
anagnorisis,
of discovery,
of self discovery for the
pilgrim.
The pilgrim poet is left by
Virgil who has guided him up to
this point,
and who will not be able to
enter paradise because he is a
pagan,
so he is left--the pilgrim is
left--
on his own to meet Beatrice.
Virgil dwells in limbo at the
entrance of Inferno,
where he is lodged with other
worthies of the pagan world,
neither punished nor rewarded.
This is a marvelous invention
of Dante's limbo,
where he puts all of these
great figures of antiquity who
could not--
since they came before Christ,
could not have been Christian,
therefore, they cannot enter
paradise,
and they're put here in limbo
where they are together in this
palace,
neither too happy nor sad,
with a kind of a smile,
a mysterious smile on their
face discussing their works with
each other.
It's a kind of a perpetual
seminar...
Not bad.
That's where Virgil dwells,
and he left to accompany the
pilgrim all the way up,
but not quite into paradise.
Of course, the whole object of
the journey was to find
Beatrice.
The pilgrim moves on to the end
of Purgatorio to be met
by Beatrice.
I will get to the solemn
procession that meets him,
and on which the one in
Cervantes is based,
but first let me tell you that
the meeting with Beatrice is,
to me, one of the funniest
moments in the whole of the
western literary tradition.
After the pilgrim poet has gone
through all of hell and most of
purgatory in order to meet her,
the first thing that Beatrice
does when they do meet is to
reproach him for having been
with other women after his
death.
I find this delicious and very,
very funny and a great lesson:
no good deed shall go
unpunished.
But what ensues in Dante is an
elaborate procession as Beatrice
appeared: at its front there
march seven luminaries,
the seven gifts of the Holy
Ghost, followed by the twenty
elders of the Apocalypse,
canticles announce the
impending arrival of Beatrice,
four mystic animals appear,
the four gospels,
and a cart pulled by a griffin;
the four cardinal virtues
follow and then the three
theological virtues with Saint
Peter and Saint Paul,
four doctors of the Church,
and St.
John.
The procession stops before the
pilgrim poet;
the triumphant Beatrice,
symbol of theology,
makes her appearance.
This is the background of the
pageant that the steward has
organized with the help of other
servants of the duke and
duchess,
including the beautiful page
playing the role of Dulcinea.
One must pause to ponder,
at least I pause to ponder,
the distance between the
universe created by Dante in
the Divine Comedy and
that created by Cervantes in
the Quixote.
The pageant in the forest is
quite a bold parody,
verging on the irreverent,
on the part of Cervantes.
What makes the difference
between Dante's and Cervantes'
world?
This is what we must ask
ourselves at this point.
In my view, is the progressive
crumbling of the certainties of
the medieval world,
the cosmology grounded on the
Ptolemaic system that has been
shattered by the discovery of
the New World and the Copernican
revolution,
the Protestant Reformation and
the schism in the Christian
Church.
The minutely ordered symbolic
universe of Christian doctrine
apparent in medieval cathedrals
and in the Divine Comedy
is no longer available.
The fusion of Neo-Platonic love
and its courtly derivatives,
which could coalesce in the
figure of Beatrice uniting
worldly love with divine love
and faith,
has been torn asunder,
so that, what Don Quixote finds
in this brilliant scene is not a
Beatrice,
but is a transvestite Dulcinea,
a transvestite Dulcinea,
no less, who reveals to him
perhaps the depths of his
madness and the true nature of
his desire.
Javier Herrero,
whom I have quoted many times
in the course of the semester,
says the following:
"It is a remarkable twist
of Cervantes' irony that the
incarnated Dulcinea is a lie of
the duke's built on a previous
lie of Sancho.
To top it all,
Dulcinea is really a man,
a page of the duke's that the
steward has selected to play
this role because of his beauty.
Such is the ontological status
of the earthly Dulcinea,
a labyrinth of lies built upon
lies of contradictory
appearances."
Unquote.
Think about this,
think about the difference
between Beatrice and this
Dulcinea.
I mean, it's a huge difference,
I mean,
between the sublime image of
Beatrice who incarnates theology
in the Divine Comedy and
this hilarious figure of the
duke's page,
who is very beautiful,
playing the role of Dulcinea.
This is the evolution of the
ideal woman from Dante to
Cervantes,
which goes through Laura in
Petrarch,
Isabel Freyre in Garcilaso,
and all of these winds up in
this brilliant figure of the
transvestite Dulcinea that we
have here,
in this pageant in the forest.
I mean, this is where Cervantes
reaches levels of penetration
into the evolution of the
western mind that are really
uncanny,
and where we have not really
gone much beyond.
Now, the pageant in the forest
is bristling with Baroque
elements;
it is the most Baroque scene in
the entire novel.
First, it takes place in a
chiaroscuro atmosphere,
and I've explained what
chiaroscuro is,
as we shall see,
a darkness that is half
illuminated by torches.
It is a fabrication,
a construction,
an assemblage of disparate
elements: theatrical,
self conscious,
humorous.
It is play and it is a play;
the carts that appear carrying
the costumed players are like
those used to represent autos
sacramentales--
remember those allegorical
autos that I have
mentioned several times,
like the one in the wagon of
the parliament of death episode.
As in much of the second part,
these are complicated
"burlas,"
pranks,
based on literary allusions,
like the cave of Montesinos
episode,
which drew from the classical
tradition and the romances of
chivalry--
remember the descent to Hades
in Homer and Virgil and one in
the romances of chivalry.
Here, in this pageant in the
forest we have,
as in the cave,
literary figures,
like Merlin and the Devil,
representing themselves.
That is, you think that a
literary figure represents
presumably a real person,
but here these are literary
figures who are representing
literary figures;
these are several layers of
fictionality here.
It is literally a dantesque
world with clear allusions,
as I've mentioned,
to Purgatorio
XXVIII-XXX; XXVIII,
XXIX, XXX.
Baroque art is,
we call it in Spanish,
"efectista";
it aims at generating reactions
on the audience of--
because of its outrageous
dimensions or its exaggerated
qualities: that's the essence of
the Baroque.
The reader is treated to the
effects of this art and shown
its effects on the spectators
and participants,
like Sancho,
who faints, and also,
its effect even on those who
are responsible for the whole
charade;
they are caught within their
own fiction, the duke and
duchess, and are scared.
The most jarring effect in this
episode is caused by sound and
if we turn to pages 695,
696, I'm going to read a
passage that begins in the last
paragraph:
"With these and the like
entertaining discourses,
they left the tent,
and went into the wood to visit
the toils and nets [this was in
the world of the hunt].
The day was soon spent,
and night came on not so clear
nor so calm as the season of the
year,
which was the midst of summer,
required,
but a kind of clair
obscur [chiaroscuro,
this is what Jarvis is trying
to get at],
which contributed very much to
help forward the duke and
duchess's design.
Now, night coming on,
soon after the twilight,
on the sudden the wood seemed
on fire from all of the four
quarters;
and presently were heard,
on all sides,
an infinite number of cornets
and other instruments of war,
as if a great body of horse was
passing through the wood.
The blaze of the fire,
and the sound of the warlike
instruments,
almost blinded and stunned the
eyes and ears of the bystanders,
and even of all that were in
the wood.
Presently were heard infinite
Lelilelies [which is a sound
that the Moors make when they
are just going to battle]
...
Trumpets and clarions sounded,
drums beat,
fifes played,
and almost all at once,
so fast and without
intermission,
that he must have had no sense,
who had not lost at the
confused din so many
instruments."
Unquote.
The "son
confuso,"
confused sound,
causes
"pasmo,"
that is,
astonishment,
"suspenso,"
suspense,
"admirac
ión,"
admiration and
"espanto,"
fright.
I'm quoting words from the
original.
The key here is the shrill,
disharmony;
the sounds are:
"ronco,"
hoarse, and
"espantoso,"
frightening.
The voices, "horr&ia
cute;sona"
horrible;
the devil is sounding a
"desaforado
cuerno,"
an outrageous horn.
They are visual effects, too.
The devils are ugly:
those "feos
demonios,"
and Merlin, as the figure of
death, is terrifying.
This whole scene is cast in
this clash of sounds and sights
artificially created for effect.
Even in the translation that I
have just read,
you can hear that Cervantes has
created this effect also
stylistically,
with harsh sounding words and
onomatopoeias;
that is, is words that sound
like what they represent.
Now, in addition to all of this
Baroque atmosphere,
Dulcinea is a transvestite,
I get back to that.
Dulcinea is a man disguised as
a beautiful woman,
more precisely,
a beautiful young man disguised
as a beautiful young woman;
it is underlined that the page
is beautiful.
This is the most outrageous of
the transformations that
Dulcinea undergoes,
even worse than her appearing
as a peasant wench smelling of
garlic: it makes her femininity
something artificial,
that can be forged with the
proper disguise.
The transvestite is a common
Baroque figure in Spanish
literature, because in the
Baroque even gender can be
constructed, fabricated.
From the ideal beauty drawn
from the Neo-Platonic and the
courtly love tradition from
which Don Quixote invents
Dulcinea to the grotesque
peasant of Sancho's lie to this
Baroque construction there is an
increase in the level of
fabrication,
of artificiality.
I guess we do invent the
objects of our desires;
this is what the novel keeps
telling us.
You've got to be careful,
you don't invent the object of
your desire, and it turns out to
be a transvestite.
I have seen some that can
really fool anybody.
I wrote a book on a Cuban
writer called Severo Sarduy,
whose chief figure is a
transvestite;
he lived in Paris and I visited
with him a few places that are
not in the tour's guides and
where you would find
transvestites that could really
fool anybody.
The grotesqueness is augmented
here and made even funnier by
the feature that exposes
Dulcinea's true gender,
which is...
her voice!
Jarvis flubs the translation,
our Jarvis.
In the original it says that
Dulcinea's voice was not very
"adamada,"
from "dama,"
lady,
"adamada."
The voice was not very
lady-like.
Jarvis renders it as
"amiable,"
oh, he ruins the whole effect.
No!
Dulcinea's voice is masculine.
She has a voice,
and when she delivers the
speech the contrast is that
she's beautiful,
because the page is beautiful
and dressed like a beautiful
woman,
but suddenly,
what emerges from her is a
hoarse voice of a male.
She has too much testosterone
and this contrast,
this clash is what is important
here, and lamentably Jarvis
flubbed it.
This whole episode makes me
think of a movie that is perhaps
too old for you to have seen it
but it's such a classic that you
may have seen it,
Some Like It Hot,
with Marilyn Monroe.
It's just a wonderful movie,
and the very last line is a
classic,
because, when the old man
is--just continues to insist
that he,
Lemon--is the--is Lemon the
guy..?--
who is playing the transvestite
finally his defense is,
"But I'm not even a
woman!,"
and then, of course,
"Nobody's perfect,"
answers her eager lover,
and, I guess,
this Dulcinea is not perfect;
I mean, first of all,
she's a man.
She may be beautiful,
and in addition to that,
she has a voice that is just
not very feminine.
This whole elaborate prank is
concocted to disenchant
Dulcinea.
To bring her out of the state
in which Sancho's lie put her,
hence the need,
within this grotesque fiction,
for Sancho to punish himself,
by giving himself three
thousand lashes on his buttocks.
The prank has a logic of its
own which operates at the level
of the lies, which are fictions
in their own right.
At that level Sancho is the
culprit, so he must pay the
price.
Now, but why lashes on his butt
and not his back?
Which is, traditionally,
prisoners are punished by
having a number of lashes
administered to their bare
backs, but here it's to his bare
bottom.
This, of course,
adds to the humor of the whole
charade, because Sancho,
of course, wants to protect his
butt.
Literally, he's not going to
have any such thing happen to
him.
But, of course,
it is an allusion to Sancho's
being so dependent on his
digestive system,
as it were.
He has already defecated twice
in the novel--
remember, in Part I,
in the fulling hammers,
and then when he takes that
concoction that Don Quixote
gives him and he has a terrible
bout of diarrhea;
so defecation and the year end
are very much a part of Sancho.
His rear, Sancho's rear
represents his fleshy character,
it is his signature as much as
his belly is in the last name
Panza.
A finale on the duke and
duchess: Joaquín
Casalduero,
a Spanish hispanist from the
forties,
says at the duke's house,
Don Quixote feels for the first
time like a real knight-errant,
but that this is not enough.
And this is the quote from
Casalduero, translated by me:
"Man's inner reality seeks
to be confirmed in society,
which when it gratifies the man
of action,
grants him a personality,
but any social confirmation of
what is spiritual is always a
parody.
Don Quixote,
a spiritual man,
sees his own image as a
knight-errant,
which he has heretofore always
contemplated in the purity of
action.
It is an image of his external
self,
the honor, social status,
the fame that society can grant
the man of the spirit are
nothing but a burlesque image of
him,
a distortion of his inner
life." Unquote.
Casalduero posits that any
manifestation of one's inner
life in the world outside has
necessarily to be burlesque,
that it cannot match its
essence in the purity of thought
and desire.
Perhaps Don Quixote is making
this discovery,
as he is subject to pranks,
like those he suffers at the
hands of the duke and the
duchess and their minions.
Now, I want to end with a few
words about The Pretended
Aunt,
because you have written a
paper to be turned in today,
in which following Auerbach and
Spitzer on the notion of the
Cervantean,
using that knowledge you apply
it to your reading of The
Pretended Aunt and try to
decide if it was written or not
by Cervantes.
This is a story that appeared
in a bundle of manuscripts that
included some of Cervantes'
stories like Rinconete and
Cortadillo, but it was not
signed.
And, of course,
the debate has raged over the
centuries as to whether it was
written by Cervantes or not.
In favor of considering the
story to be Cervantes I would
say that Esperanza is an
independent young woman who
shapes her future by dint of her
will and courage;
she rebels and winds up married
to a well-to-do young man;
she erases her past as a whore
and becomes respectable and
married.
In this, she is like other
Cervantes characters,
like Marcela,
Dorotea and Zoraida,
and also in favor of--
the story ends with an unequal
marriage similar to those in
the,
a successful one at that.
Against it being by Cervantes,
is the strong,
too strong influence of
Celestina,
above all in the salacious
episodes and details about
repairing virgins.
There is nothing quite as dirty
in any text by Cervantes,
including The Deceitful
Marriage and The Dogs
Colloquy,
stories that you will be
reading towards the end of the
semester.
It could be--a way out could
be--is that, it could be by an
early Cervantes story before he
was Cervantes;
it could be a Cervantes
imitator who wrote it and so
forth, but how many of you here
thought that it was written by
Cervantes, raise your hands?
One, two, three, four.
How many thought not?
How many didn't take a side?
You didn't take any sides?
Student:
>
Prof: Not fair.
Okay.